on
oui
j
bonjour à toutes et à tous et oui ces
chevaux que vous voyez courir ces
taureaux que vous voyez aussi dans les
rues de vendargues
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui en ce 20
juillet 1976 nous avons choisi de vous
présenter à villages de france
en fait l'actualité est là bien sûr il
ya ce qui s'est passé a nice c'est 200
coffres qui ont été fracturées c est
considéré aujourd'hui comme le plus
grand casse du siècle
nous allons en parler dans un instant
avec michel denisot il ya bien sûr les
jeux olympiques il y a la cote des
hommes politiques tout cela nous le
verrons dans un instant presque
immédiatement et si j'ai voulu
aujourd'hui consacré cette édition de
tf1 actualité 13h à la fête à vendargues
c'est parce que vandales fait partie de
ces villages de france où malgré l'été
malgré les estivants et bien le village
continue à vivre et c'est un village en
fête et non pas des estivants en fait
que vous verrez aujourd'hui cela fait
partie un petit peu de l'image de la
france au mois de juillet eh bien tous
ces jeunes toute cette population qui
réunit autour de nous nous allons passer
trois quarts d'heure avec elle en
compagnie
nelly jean laffon c'est ici qu'est la
des hommes les plus célèbres de la
région parle pas de chevaux et taureaux
sans parler sur la faune nous recevrons
également un amoureux de la région jean
carrière qui sera avec le tout à l'heure
ils recevront également manitas de plata
qui nous a fait la grande joie de venir
aujourd'hui tout spécialement participé
à cette édition de tf1 actualité mais
tout de suite et pendant que la peña de
lunel joue sur ces arènes de vendargues
et bien je vous propose de regarder
l'ensemble de l'actualité et michel
denisot
oui d'abord avec le fric frac de nice
dont vous parliez à l'instant c'est très
loin le plus importante qui ait jamais
été commis sur la côte d'azur
peut-être même en france il faudra
attendre plusieurs jours pour connaître
le montant du butin les policiers
estiment d'ores et déjà à 4 ou 5
milliards de centimes
si ces chiffres sont confirmés on
parlera bien sûr de hold up du siècle
en attendant il y à déjà 5 certitude 1
200 coffres de la société générale ont
été forcées au chalumeau 2 les
malfaiteurs étaient au moins 6 3 ils
sont venus par les égouts 4 ils ont
creusé une galerie de 6 mètres et 5
ils ont travaillé quarante huit heures
sans interruption et tout cela s'est
passé à 200 mètres de la sûreté de nice
selon un scénario digne des meilleurs
films policiers regardez c'était
générale à nice elle ne connaît toujours
pas le montant exact du butin
selon le commissaire besson chargé de
l'enquète 304 particuliers ont été
forcées sur 4000 les réserves en espèces
de la banque et les recettes des grandes
surfaces ont disparu pour entrer dans la
banque les bandits sont passés par les
égouts puis ont creusé un tunnel de 10
mètres
le cambriolage a été découvert lundi
matin après que les employés aient dû
forcer la salle des coffres car ni
malfaiteurs on avait su delaporte
donateurs en ce moment une foule
nombreuse se pressent sur les grilles
vos questions se posent pourquoi ni avec
qui aucun gardien durant le week-end
dans la banque
comment les bandits anti algues et des
systèmes automatiques de sécurité se
dont brio leur devait être au moins six
puisque l'on a trouvé six chats lumière
ex hydrique sur les vieux leur foi fait
ils n'ont accompli en toute quiétude
lange en paix même du vin durant leur
travail et policiers de l'office central
de répression du banditisme sont arrivés
de paris ce matin
cette affaire présentent des points
communs avec celle de la borne hervé de
même qu'elle ressemble étrangement à un
cambriolage commis dans une banque
italienne
il ya quelques mois quant au plan de la
générale il s'étonne d'avoir appuyé la
faire par là
très bon y'a pas
le groupe était ouvert madame roux dont
vous avez beaucoup achètent pas pratique
pas pu rentrer voir l'état des choses
disons que je veux dire monsieur kita
scandale c'est que ça c'est pas vrai dit
non soit je pars en voyage et tout
encore j'estime que lundi je suis un
club depuis 40 ans il téléphone ils ont
mono il pouvait me prévenir hier à ce
moment là j'aurais mis arrêt sur mon
conseil postale sur mon compte de la
parole sur mes complices et plus du tout
tout tout un hold up de plus faible
envergure que le casse de nice ce matin
à trappes dans les yvelines de gangsters
armés de pistolets ont raflé sept cent
mille francs dans les locaux de la
société parisienne et méridionale de
travaux publics les conditions de ce
hold up sont mal établie pour l'instant
si ce but un des gangsters de nice et de
trappes perd de sa valeur ne l'ait
plaindront pas mais il est certain que
ces milliards de centimes qu'ils ont
empoché sous des formes diverses fonde
légèrement en effet tous les francs
volés ou non sont en baisse
la décote de notre monnaie s'est
accentuée hier le dollar approchait la
barre de 5 francs le signal d alarme est
déclenchée
alors voyons ce qui se passe en ce
moment à la bourse de paris avec
françois donné à la course le signal
d'alarmé
c'était un sur le franc déjà c'était le
cas hier au moment où je vous parle est
le franc avait commencé à remonter et
cette remontée est confirmée on l'a noté
qu'il y avait très peu de volume
d'actions au moment où le franc baisser
et cette étroitesse des orgues montre
bien qu'il n'y a pas eu de panique et
que la baisse devait s'employer
d'elle-même puisque les spéculateurs ont
pris peur face à la possibilité d'une
intervention de la banque de france
aujourd'hui effectivement le taux
d'intérêt à court terme l'argent au jour
le jour a été encore relevés par les
autres par les autorités monétaires ce
qui tend à attirer des capitaux
étrangers chez nous toujours est il que
le dollar est retombé à l'heure où je
vous parle à 4 francs 90 et demi c'est à
dire qu'il a baissé presque de 2
centimes le franc suisse a baissé d'un
centime vis-à-vis du franc français le
deutschmark avait séduit aussi d'un
centime vis-à-vis du franc français ce
n'est pas bien sûr une remontée mais
c'est une stabilisation un arrêt du
mouvement des attaques contre le franc
la spéculation pour l'instant se tient
tranquille on ne sait pas clairement
quelle va être la suite du mouvement
mais on veut penser que ceux qui avaient
vendu du franc français a découvert vont
tendre à se racheter pour ne pas subir
de pair
et que l'armée d'armistice pourrait par
conséquent durer un certain temps avoue
michel denisot paradoxe ou plutôt marque
de confiance dans un moment difficile le
ministre des finances jean pierre
fourcade est la seule personnalité de la
majorité a gagné un point baromètre
mensuel figaro sofres tous les autres
sont en baisse jacques chirac perd un
point au classement général et dix
points au classement particulier auprès
de l'électorat du dr la majorité
s'effrite l'opposition de la grignotte
sur cette photographie de l'opinion
françois mitterrand georges marchais
robert favre et pierre mauroy gagnent
tous un point enfin la hausse des prix
est la principale préoccupation des
français
la lutte contre le chômage venant en
deuxième position c'est dans une heure à
peu près une heure et 4 minutes
à 14h12 exactement que vikings à mars
ira en clair la sonde américaine viking
1 se posera sur mars
le mystère de cette planète mars sera
percé si tout se passe bien ce soir nous
verrons des photos de cette planète
comme si nous y étions pour l'instant se
déroule à 300 millions de même 300
millions de kilomètres une manoeuvre
très complexe la descente de laitages
d'atterrissage de viking sur la surface
martienne
michel chevalet oui michel denisot à 15
100 km au dessus de la surface de mars
gravitent en ce moment cet engin de
weezy si la maquette c'est le viking
maquette que l'on doit notre ami louis
dumont donc les opérations de rentrée
dans l'atmosphère martienne et de chute
vers le sol de la planète ont donc déjà
commencé et l'opération 2
si vous voulez l'atterrissage ce qu'on
dit atterrissage sur mars en douceur et
bien se produira à 14h12 et les
américains ont mis cette fois ci le
maximum de chances de leur côté
alors je propose c'est que l'on regarde
en images déjà la suite de ces
opérations
tout d'abord de l'engin se détache une
espèce de capsule c'est dans cette
capsule que se trouve le viking pendant
que l'autre partie continue de tourner
en orbite
ensuite en en 20 minutes combustion des
moteurs de façon à faire décrocher
d'engins l'orbité vous voyez ici la
simulation au sol tel que l'ont fait les
américains orientations de la capsule
vers le soleil de façon à tuer les
bactéries
pas question bien sûr de contaminer le
sol martien puis à 260km attitude 16
milles à l'heure le freinage sur
l'atmosphère
seulement ce freinage est insuffisant la
pression la surface de mars n'est que le
centième de celle qui existe sur terre
d'où ouverture d'un parachute qui va
ralentir l'engin jusqu'à 250 à l'heure
ensuite eh bien on déploie les pieds du
viking et on va larguer le parachute de
façon à ce qu'il ne recouvre pas l'engin
il faut y sera posée au sol et enfin
troisième et dernier freinage celui avec
des rétrofusées un peu lorsque l'on
s'est posée sur la lune avec appolo est
là et bien il y a dix huit petits jets
des trois moteurs de façon à ce que ces
gènes pollue pas le sol de la planète
vous voyez qu'on multiplie les
précautions et enfin regarder
l'atterrissage est à dire dès que le qui
touchent le sol les moteurs sont coupés
voilà donc théoriquement ce qui doit se
passer à 14h12 en somme à 14h12 sur le
sol de mars il y aura cet engin c'est à
dire le viking qui braquera vers la
terre cette antenne de façon à nous
donner les premières photos ce qu'il
faut bien voir d'or c'est que dans cette
opération
et bien ce que vous venez de voir ici en
animation c'est en quelque sorte la
partie la plus spectaculaire la plus
facile pour nous mais ce n'est que la
partie émergée d'un iceberg car après
une fois sur le sol est bien pendant
près de trois mois
l'engin pourra
faire en travail scientifique très
important dont nous aurons l'occasion de
reparler des au soir mais je pense que
dès ce soir nous pouvons vous montrer
des gros plans et en couleurs s'il vous
plaît du panorama martial en bref suite
du voyage officiel du président
camerounais ahmadou ahidjo à paris il a
eu un deuxième entretien à l'elysée ce
matin avec valéry giscard d'estaing
auparavant le président camerounais
était allé se recueillir
l'arc de triomphe sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu et hier soir il avait été l'hôte
d'honneur d'un dîner donné à l'elysée ce
soir le président ahidjo recevra à son
tour le président de la république
française
ouganda une équipe d'air france est à
kampala pour remettre en état les rebuts
s'immobiliser à hanter b la compagnie
française s'apprête à reprendre
possession de son appareil paul 6
viennent de nommer deux évêques
auxiliaires auprès du cardinal marty
archevêque de paris s'agit des abbés
gilson et de gens remarquent liban la
tendance est à la modération les
palestiniens seraient prêts à négocier
avec les syriens se l'est après un mois
et demi de sanglants affrontements
commentaires de jean loup de mieux les
islamo progressiste et la droite
chrétienne sont d'accord sur un point au
liban les syriens ont envoyé ces jours
ci des renforts dont une trentaine de
blindés
autre certitude les phalangistes tir de
la montagne vers beyrouth et l'enfant on
se dirige peut-être vers des
négociations
le commandant jalloud de premier
ministre libyen qui tente une médiation
au liban depuis 45 jours à communiquer
aux palestiniens les conditions syrienne
pour entamer un dialogue
le commandement central palestine aux
progressistes accepte l'une d'entre
elles et annonce aujourd'hui l'envoi
damas du chef du département politique
de l'olp
cependant il ne semble pas vraisemblable
que cesse rapidement la guerre de
propagande entre la syrie et la
résistance palestinienne et que cessent
les affrontements sanglants qui dure
depuis un mois et demi
quant à la dernière proposition du
président fin janvier de déporter les
palestiniens vers les autres pays arabes
elle ne peut pas plaire à yasser arafat
il sera plus facile ce soir d'estimer
les chances de règlement du conflit
en prenant connaissance du discours que
doit prononcer sur le problème
palestinien le président syrien hafez
el-assad
l'équipe du rss du pantalon était
disqualifié il ya quelques heures motifs
boris onichtchenko est accusé d'avoir
triché à l'épée onichtchenko était le
favori pour la médaille d'or nous allons
peut-être le voir disputer et gagner le
titre mondial à londres en 74 si nous
avons reçu les images pense que nous
allons les avoir nous l'entendons le
voilà alors que s'est-il passé hier
onichtchenko que l'on voit ici recevoir
les médailles dont les championnats du
monde a été disqualifié à l'issue de son
combat contre le britannique jeremy fox
alors que fox n'avait pas été touchée le
signal lumineux indiquant une touche en
faveur du soviétique s'est allumé alors
fox a protesté
onichtchenko a été disqualifié
l'épée ne m'appartient pas a dit ce
dernier cet ep est truqué a dit le
président du jury alors pour savoir
comment on pouvait en arriver là comment
on pouvait trouille truquer une épée
dans une compétition aussi importante
que celle des jeux olympiques nous avons
sur ce plateau m séné qui va d'abord
nous expliquer comment marchent les
paies et comment fonctionne le signal
lumineux quand rien et truquées quand
tout est normal
et alors le fonctionnement est très
simple une simple pression de 700
grammes sur la tête de pointe ici allume
l'appareil qui se trouvent ici derrière
moi
ce qui permet de voir quel est le tireur
qui est touché alors là moyen de tricher
si on veut c'est de réunir ici les fils
à l'intérieur parce que les fils à
l'intérieur de larmes sont isolés si
bien que dès que les fils sont en
contact le on obtient le même résultat
que si on appuie sur la tête de pointe
c'est-à-dire l'allumage de l'appareil
s'agit de faire un court circuit et
c'est à dire oui en fait faire un court
circuit c'est à dire qu'on réunit les
deux fils isolé à l'intérieur de leur
intérieur de la coquille alors on a
parlé de d'engins électronique
je ne prends son pari que d'engins
électronique je ne pense pas que kate
pour l'instant d'argent électronique le
principe est fort simple de réunir deux
fils je ne pense pas que il ya eu usage
appareils électroniques mais je suppose
que les épées sont tout de même contrôlé
avant les épreuves
les épées sont contrôlés avant les
épreuves la veille ils sont contrôlés et
avant chaque épreuve l'épée est
contrôlée alors il est possible que
qu'on lui ait changé son arme mais enfin
ça m'étonnerait de sceptiques est ce que
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
incident se produit dans une grande
compétition
on a eu des cas même parmi les français
les cas sont arrivés m'enfin c'est très
rare bien mettre je vous remercie
revenons aux compétitions régulières
avec le résumé de la dernière journée à
noter la remarquable performance de
l'équipe de france de football qui a
battu le mexique par 4 buts à 1
à noter surtout voilà je vous demande
pardon à noter surtout la pluie de
records en natation et nous allons voir
les principales épreuves de cette
dernière jour cette deuxième journée des
jeux olympiques avec hannachi à la ligne
d'eau numéro qu'a cornelia ender à sa
droite l'année les guincheurs les babas
chauffe encouragé par le public
excellent départ de la halle
delhaize qui prend immédiatement la tête
al ahly numéro 1 sa compatriote primeur
est également fort bien parti les deux
américaines babanov et peyton sont déjà
dominé aux 25 mètres enders a déjà une
demi longueur d'avancé 27 secondes 10
centièmes à la culbute
on sent venir le record du monde qui est
de 55 secondes 73 centièmes ender n'a
pas réussi son virage primer tout angle
être ensemble la rattraper mais non la
supériorité de cornelia ender est
évidente aux 75 m elle possède une
longueur d'avancé dans quelques secondes
le record du monde va tomber ender va
réaliser 55 secondes 65 100e médaille
d'argent pour l'autre allemande de l'est
primeur médaille de bronze pour la
hollandaise brigitte a aucune américaine
ne montera sur le podium
autre grand moment de cette soirée de
natation la finale du 100 m dos
messieurs on s'attend à une lutte très
serrée entre l'allemand de l'est rôle en
maths est quatre fois champion olympique
un mythe si cauet munich
al ahly numéro 3 et l'américain john
labeur à sa gauche
li numéro 4 qui a battu le record du
monde de la spécialité au cours des demi
finales en fait le duel n'aura pas lieu
matt est ce qui a provoqué deux faux
départs est dominé dès le début de
l'épreuve par l'américain qui
irrésistiblement se détache 26 secondes
55 au 50 m sans aucun doute le record du
monde va une nouvelle fois être battu il
sera en fait pulvériser nab heures va
réaliser 55 secondes 49 centièmes
derrière lui son compatriote rod qallali
numéro 5 va obtenir la médaille d'argent
tandis que roland matthès arrachera
celle de bronze à montréal la valse des
records à commencer les partenaires
l'allemagne de l'est et les états unis
deux rendez vous olympique aujourd'hui
sur tf1 d'abord le résumé de 17h à 19h
et le direct à partir de 22h30 jusqu'à
une heure assez avancée de la nuit
la météo de ce 20 juillet cet après-midi
temps très nuageux à couvert avec de
faibles pluies au nord ouest d'une ligne
la rochelle auxerre strasbourg et au sud
de cette ligne soleil avec quelques
orages sur l'extrême sud est
demain éclaircies sur le nord-ouest
températures en baisse brouillards
matinaux sur le sud-ouest ailleurs
soleil et mistral assez fort dans la
vallée du rhône nous retournons à van
darc dans l'hérault numéro minéralogique
34 morosi
et
il
un espace d'éclat taxe est notre invité
aujourd'hui au 10e
les gardians présente les traditionnels
jeux de camargue dans ses arènes avec
les arts visuels résidence des plata qui
se sent qui se sent un peu chez lui ici
et oui j'ai ici avec la guitare avec le
soleil avec les chevaux les taureaux
lorsque vous êtes dans cette région où
vous n'êtes plus souvent définitive
parce que votre carrière internationale
fait que vous êtes à travers la france à
travers le monde entier pour des pour
des galas lorsque vous vous retrouvez
ici c'est un peu de votre coeur que vous
retrouvez au oui beaucoup
et toi tu es gentil je suis gentil
j'essaye de lettres du soleil incite à
la gentillesse ici veritas des plats
écrivain aussi be ce que vous avez écrit
un livre qui s'appelle musicaux doigt un
livre publié aux éditions robert laffont
ça pue m'étonner un moment quand j'ai vu
m'a dit tu as des plateaux écrivain oui
mais c'est pour moi quelque chose et de
bandes se tenait à paris
lucien
la quelle on fait un bouquin quoi tu
l'as lu non mais ma femme l'a lu ça lui
va oui toi bien merci
mécontente mali parce qu'on va retrouver
très bientôt à travers la france pour un
certain nombre de récitals alors je dois
vous dire tout de suite qu'il sera le 22
juillet au tréport le 23 au touquet le
25 à chis près de niort et qu'il faudra
attendre dans la région le le 31 juillet
pour retrouver manitas de plata et ça se
passera cette fois ci à arles et tu ne
seras pas tout seul alors il ya beaucoup
y la 10ème quitter san jose il ya
n'était pas grande roue cyr et
j'espérais qu'il a beaucoup digital
entoure ce soit dans les arènes dont un
théâtre antique et dans le théâtre
antique le 31 juillet donc manita sera
de retour en arles on dit en arles loire
tu t'en fiches il sera ardu le coeur
d'un camargue au coeur de la camargue
cette camargue jean carrière que que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous n'avez
pas eu beaucoup de chemin pour venir
vous prix goncourt ici même à vendargues
pour célébrer la fête de vendargues car
c'est une seule
c'est une fête en définitive comme on en
voit peu parce que on a trop tendance à
être touriste et on oublie que la france
bat au rythme de ces fêtes dans tous ces
villages partout et ce qui est
formidable à vendargues
c'est que et on le découvre les
téléspectateurs l'ont découverte dès le
début de cette émission il y à toute la
population site
on dit souvent les jeunes les vieux ici
c'est la population d'un village qui
fait la fête
c'est pour une bonne raison c'est que ce
peuple à la fête dans le sang et la
seule chose qu'on pourrait souhaiter
c'est qu'ils continuent à vivre ici qui
sont pas obligés d'aller travailler
ailleurs 200 av de s'exiler pour
continuer finalement à trouver le
bonheur dans ce pays qui a toujours été
la cible
le pays du bonheur c'est la civilisation
du bonheur il s'agit qu'elle continue il
ya un peintre devant d'art qui s'appelle
monsieur tessier qui a peint la camargue
et qui lui a donné des couleurs
ils ont découvert assez neutre et
pourtant le soleil est là en permanence
oui parce que je crois que en fait le
soleil est un dévoreur du dévoreur de
lumière et c'est très intéressant comme
peintre moi je crois cette région en
noir et blanc
c'est une région que j'ai toujours du
noir comme l'écrivait noires et blanches
région pastel temps map un petit peu
pour la camargue à cause des flamants
roses dans carrière l'a fait on en parle
souvent on la craie pour les estivants à
travers les plages à travers les casinos
à travers les différents endroits où les
gens vont en vacances si on oublie
souvent la fête au coeur même de la
france telle qu'elle vit la fête au
coeur même de la france c'est peut-être
ça le grand problème qui est soulevée
par le tourisme
nous sommes dans une époque où le
tourisme risquent de se transformer en
camp de concentration
il est déjà un peu comme ça je crois
qu'il faudrait que les touristes se
rendent compte qu'il faut apporter
beaucoup de soi-même pour trouver le
bonheur d'un dans les vacances enfin
essayer de retourner peut-être auprès
des
dessertenne joie simple par exemple je
pense au tourisme à la ferme je pense au
tourisme en lozère je pense au tourisme
et chez les paysans
c'est une manière de se recycler de
retrouver les vraies valeurs et de ne
pas tomber dans cette caricature de la
caricature de la fête caricature du
tourisme qui est souvent malheureusement
c'est une migration vers le soleil avec
les autoroutes avec toutes ces misères
vous parliez tout à l'heure de des
couleurs que vous voyez en camargue des
couleurs que vous voyez que vous rendez
à travers vos livres joseph noémie
célestin et autres paysans d'ardèche qui
est l'un de vos dernier ouvrage est un
ouvrage qui n'est pas seulement de
carrière qui est aussi la photographe
michel josé cas vous croyez que c'est un
apport supplémentaire à la littérature
la photographie oui je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que en l'occurrence j'y
pense parce que lucien clergue été cités
tout à l'heure par notre avis manitas
lucien clergue qui a qui a lui aussi
montré la camargue montrer la vie de
cette de cette région que je vais vous
dire parce que la fiction le romain ont
fait la fiction pure c'est une chose qui
appartient à la littérature c'est un
univers qui est presque un petit peu
abstrait je crois qu'en l'occurrence là
pour les paysans ardèche comme pour les
paysans cévenols lozère en fait il
s'agissait en fait ne veux pas faire un
livre de distraction mais de faire
presque
malheureusement le constat d'une
civilisation qui est en train de
disparaître et je crois qu'aucune aucun
écriveur au monde n'aurait pu restituer
la simple qualité de vie de ces gens là
sont des gens qui n'ont pas dit levy
non pas quelques fois la télévision qui
l'ont qui n'avaient pas rentrer toute sa
vie voiture ni machines à laver ni rien
de tout ça et c'était tout simplement
des jeunes qui étaient heureux
c'est aussi bête que ça la cave dix
hommes de dispagne le bonheur on le
retrouvera quand même dans dans la
caverne des pestiférés qui sera votre
prochain livre
oui je vous remercie de cette publicité
mais le livre est pas terminée il m'a
demandé trois ans de travail
c'est en effet le thème du bonheur parce
que je crois que le thème du bonheur est
profondément enraciné dans cette région
et dans ce pays vous êtes très
différents aujourd'hui du prix goncourt
ben écoute et j'en ai profité pour
prendre un peu mes distances je me suis
arrêté de travailler pendant deux ans
c'était la faute du prix goncourt mais
je crois je ne fais pas partie de ces
écrivains affaire qui forment des livres
comme on fabrique des saucisses ils font
qu'un livre soit une belle aventure et
une aventure de bonheur parce qu'il
s'agit encore de bonheur finalement je
vais partie aussi de ces gens qui se
croient comme tous ceux qui sont ici
dans ces arènes aujourd'hui préfèrent
leur passion à leurs intérêts moi aussi
je préfère ma passion les intérêts
j'aurais pu continuer à écrire des
romans mais aussi de l'écrire mais
c'était plus simple quand j'avais envie
de faire autre chose il faut ça te crois
qu'un livre sont pour moi une aventure
d'amour que ça a été le cas pour la
caverne des pestiférés je vous dis un
peu ça en fait c'est un hommage que
j'aurais an passé à marcel pagnol
c'est lui qui avait trouvé le thème de
ce livre il ne l'a pas fait il veut en
faire le film il est mort je reprends le
thème à sa place geagea carrière en tout
cas une région ne veut pas se concevoir
on ne parlons que de ces fed sans parler
de sa vie quotidienne et la vie
quotidienne ici dans quelques semaines
ce seront les vendanges et vendant je
vous le savez les derniers ont entraîné
un certain nombre de problèmes et en
particulier des manifestations alors où
en est-on dans la région de ce côté-ci
un reportage de michel denisot
actuellement nous sommes en train
d'étudier un projet d'accord
interprofessionnel à la demande
d'ailleurs du commerce
et disons que nous sommes en train de
voir l'intérieur de la profession dans
l'interprofession ce qui peut être
réalisé
est-ce que cet accord interprofessionnel
débouchera sur une amélioration je
l'espère quant à moi car j'ai la
conviction de le faire du côté de la
viticulture de soi du côté du commerce
et que ce soit du côté du gouvernement
il y a quand même
certaines bonnes volontés qui semble se
manifester pour de l'accord sont
réalisées sur des bases saines ne
voulons pas recruter des incidents comme
ceux l'an dernier vous savez ça les
incidents sont toujours à redouter parce
que les gens sont mécontents en quelque
sorte la récolte 8 975 c'est commercial
hiver les conditions extrêmement
difficiles et par conséquent nous sommes
toujours à la veille et d'événements
graves des aspirations et la colère sont
les sentiments qui quelquefois ne se
mesure pas en avoir eu la preuve au mois
de mars dernier il malheureusement et
nous souhaitons
quant à nous professionnels de ces
événements ne se renouvelle pas et
lambretta il nous faut à tous ceux qui
nous en offre dans le landeau roumanie
pour générer le mans se reprit fallavier
voilà je crois qu'il était nécessaire
en passant par cette région d'évoquer
quand même ce problème car on ne peut
pas l'ignorer lorsqu'on fait de la
formation tout à l'heure pendant que
jean carrière parler avec moi que
manitas de plata jouer que vous avez vu
des toiles de notre ami tessier et bien
les gardians tournait il se livrer au
jeu traditionnel de la camargue avec ses
arlésiennes ses gardians cc hommes de
chevaux vous les connaissez bien jean
laffon ce sont des ce sont beaucoup de
jeunes nous avons vu tout à l'heure
tourne et des jeunes qui ont la passion
du cheval la passion du cheval la
passion du taureau ça existe toujours
ici
oui oui je crois que ça existe toujours
même de plus en plus et je n'ai pas le
nombre de vocations de gardians qui me
je reçois sans anelka un tas de lettres
de gens des gens qui me demandent du
travail hélas on ne va pas tous les
satisfaire mais ce que les gardians
c'est encore disons un travail qui peut
être rentable passionnant d'abord je
crois que c'est plus intéressant qu
enfin mais est ce que c'est un travail
passionnant au moment où ils ont on a
détruit qu'on va une partie de la
camargue eh bien oui on en a détruit une
partie de la camargue mais enfin
maintenant on pense un peu à la protégée
alors je pense que ça va se stabiliser
comme ça cet après midi dans ces mêmes
arènes il y aura il y aura des taureaux
de jean laffon puisque ce sera une
course royal pourquoi course e royal à
ça je n'ai jamais su que tout le monde
l'est républicain nos esprits c'est
peut-être les taureaux qui sont les rois
ce sont les rois et bien je vous propose
tout de suite de faire rentrer à
taureaux dès que ou plutôt de faire
sortir at euros si vous voulez bien nous
jouer la sortie du taureau maestro et
bien ce taureau qui va sortir sous les
acclamations
c'est un taureau un peu particulier et
ce taureau que nous allons amener na
l'apparemment rien d'agressif et sous
les acclamations de la population je
pense que nous allons avoir la joie de
faire à face à face assez inhabituel
j'ai rencontré jusqu'à présent des
hommes politiques
j'ai rencontré des écrivains j'ai
rencontré des vedettes du show-business
je ne m'étais jamais approché aussi près
d'un taureau est ce que je hais ce que
je risque quelque chose
non je le passe à paris turf et boisés
et apprivoiser si je lui dis ah si il
s'assied en can europe couché non plus
la lune au coucher la nuit mais sur sur
mes ordres ne marcherait pas en tout cas
si j'ai ce verre d'une boisson locale à
la main et jeudi d'une boisson locale du
monde aura deviné mais je ne veux pas
citer son nom parce qu'autrement ce
serait de la publicité pour une boisson
alcoolisée ce qui est absolument
interdit à la télévision
et bien si gso verre à la main c'est
parce que ce taureau est effectivement
il ya longtemps que vous l'avez il a
quel âge il en a il s'appelle comment
birot birot alors biro bois paraît-il
c'est du moins ce qu'on m'a dit lorsque
je suis arrivé dans la région et du
reste il sent que j'ai un verre de ce
pastaga à la main et et je suppose qu'il
a envie de boire il boit si on lui donne
à boire
il sort d'une crise de foie oui
bien le pharmacien de vendargues a
certainement fait bien les choses ce
matin et je crois que la dose n'est pas
très forte
je voudrais que bear ou biro biro
j'aurais que miro boivent bureau sous
les faire boire biro parce que ça
m'étonne toujours un voilà bien ça c'est
quand même très rare et je me demande si
le corps de bèze où les autres ont fait
je peux lui en mettre un peu les voilà
eh ben voilà pouvez l'applaudir car
c'est quand même assez rare assez rare
de voir un taureau qui voit de cette
façon mais nous avons réussi à faire
boire le taureau ce qui n'est quand même
pas triste
en réalité jean laffon des taureaux il y
en a encore assez dans la région pour
que la région reste ce qu'elle est ou
est ce qu'elle a été il y en a il y en a
toujours il ya même de plus en plus de
courses
pas de danger de ce côté là et au point
de vue élevage au point de vue élevage
aussi via une bonne cinquantaine viande
de taureau camaro croiser espagnol pour
d'autres courses
puis il ya quand même les maladies d'une
106 vie qui s'y sont tous par retrouver
dans cette affaire de d'aménagement de
la côte languedoc-roussillon est ce que
cela aujourd'hui ont des grosses
difficultés
eh bien oui à nantes il y en a qu une
des grosses difficultés ce qui était de
l'autre côté d'eux
du grand rhône dans la région de fort si
l'on était plus ou moins expropriés et
certains ont eu du mal à trouver a
retrouvé des pâturages mais enfin on a
tâché nos tâches et de les aider la
réserve de camargue qui possède
certaines terres
lalanne a concédé pense que ça peut
s'arranger par solide avec soul et un
peu de solidarité un peu solidarité et
la volonté de garder quand même à la
camargue malgré ce qui s'est passé de
garder à la camargue son caractère est
aujourd'hui de tout faire pour qu'elle
reste ce qu'elle a été eh bien oui
toulouse tout le monde de tâches de s'y
mettre un peu du haut rhin en tout cas
on ne peut pas parler de vendargues on
ne peut pas parler de de ce coin de
france sans parler des taureaux et qui
dit euros dit automatiquement
accompagnement musical
tout à l'heure vous avez vu au début de
cette édition de tf1 actualité la
fameuse peña de lunel qui est toujours
salué par les ovations du public
lunel lunel et tenta un petit village ou
plutôt un village à côté devant d'art
qui lui aussi possède sa fête cas à peu
près pendant trois mois dans la région
on est en fait quel que soit le temps
mais le temps est toujours très beau de
sorte que ça ne gêne personne de faire
la fête et quand la fête sera fini avant
d'argent ni râle à faire à côté
la penya de lunel va se remettre au
travail dans un instant car nous allons
annoncer la sortie quand même d'une bête
de se tord il une bête foudroyante je
suis sûr mais comme je n'ai absolument
pas la capacité du speaker habituel
je n'ai pas la capacité du speaker
habituels pour faire les annonces
je laisserai à mon ami jacky qui se
trouve à la tribune de la direction le
soin d'annoncer non le soin d'annoncer
dans un instant le moment qui va suivre
car il est bien évident que la en
particulier les gens qui sont derrière
la barrière comme moi risque beaucoup et
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
mais qui dit fête dans un village tels
que van damme ne peut dire que fait avec
les taureaux cet après midi mais tout de
suite je crois que nous avons deux
spécimens à vous présenter alors si vous
voulez bien lancé l'opération sortie du
taureau est entré des toréadors
non
à
m
et bien voilà nous allons nous quitter
dans un instant sur ces images d'un
village en fait celui de vendargues qui
est un peu l'image de ces villages
français ou voulons regarder en ce
moment et qui eux aussi profitent de cet
été pour célébrer les fêtes de la
population c'est une réunion de
communauté et bien voilà qui donne une
image agréable de la la vie française
telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle existe
et elle que nous devons en prendre
conscience même si nous sommes quelques
fois citadins ou tourisme il me reste à
vous dire au revoir à toutes et à tous
nous allons nous quitter mais auparavant
et bien françois de netiv ou qui est à
la bourse
paré pour la corrida il est bien dommage
que be rôles viennent pas faire un tour
ici autour de la corbeille parce que le
taureau vous le savez peut-être est le
symbole de la hausse en bourse est
aujourd'hui en bourse ce n'est pas la
rose c'est plutôt le léger effritement
qui succède à la légère hausse d'hier la
hausse du franc pourtant c'est une bonne
impression mais quand elle s'accompagne
d'un relèvement des taux d'intérêt il
est assez normal que les opérateurs
hésitent à acheter des valeurs
françaises en se demandant si j'étais
hausse des taux d'intérêt ne va pas
freiner l'extension et entraîner un
risque de stagnation
il y a tout de même des exceptions par
rapport à cette baisse b saint gervais
danone monte de 3 francs mais c'est
surtout michelin qui fait une hausse
importante aujourd'hui de 18 francs
michelin pour lequel sur lequel la revue
american business fait que vient de
publier une étude très favorables
montrant que les chances de michelin sur
le marché américain vis-à-vis des grands
concurrents que sont rogers et freins
ashton sont intacts et même très grande
pour le reste il y à la baisse des mines
d'or qui spectaculaire où elle stresse
fontaine par exemple à 98 francs perd
plus de 3% et nous verrons tout à
l'heure que cela est dû à une chute
brutale des cours de l'or mais voyons
d'abord les baisses des valeurs
françaises l'aquitaine et plusieurs
autres valeurs pétrolières aujourd'hui
sont parmi les baisses les plus
importantes en effet les sociétés qui
recherchent du pétrole en mer d'iroise
ont annoncé que la campagne de
recherches était terminé demain
infructueuses pour cette année elle
reprendra seulement l'année prochaine
d'autres nouvelles le contraire sont
plus favorables en particulier en ce qui
concerne pernod ricard et qui est aubois
son monde sensiblement aujourd'hui et
sur certaines valeurs de construction
électrique comme la hesta telle alstom
alors qu'au contraire moulinex et
d'autres valeurs de ce compartiment sont
en baisse il ya donc une irrégularité
incontestable aujourd'hui à la bourse de
paris
alors c'est donc la chute est parmi les
eaux cependant il ya celle du des
ciments et qu'ils n'ont pas à cause de
la hausse de leur chiffre d'affaires
mais à cause des perspectives
d'augmentation de leurs bénéfices grâce
à la rationalisation qu'elles ont pu
opérer de lui aujourd'hui un petit
courant d'achat alors baisse
spectaculaire puisque le lingot le
napoléon d'abord à 218 fonds perd 7
francs et le zinc ou à 18 500 francs
pierre 530 francs leur baisse jean chute
verticale sur tous les marchés étrangers
levels étrangères sont en baisse elle
aussi d'abord parce que wall street
avait baissé et ensuite parce que le
franc remonte il ya donc un effet normal
mais les mines d'or font une baisse
beaucoup plus importante que le reste
l'enfant quatre et demi pourcent 1973
lui même c'est de congés néral à 583 il
fait une baisse de cinq points et demi
par rapport à son cours d'hier est pas
aussi c'est la première fois depuis
longtemps que cette valeur qui était la
vedette numéro un est de faire son tour
touchée par la baisse ici la bourse
avoue yves mourousi si françois 2010
pour ces précisions il me reste
maintenant à souhaiter à tous un très
bon président
et de souhaiter à toute la population de
vendargues et à toutes les populations
de france aujourd'hui
en fait comme dans ce village la
meilleure fait possible et peut-être
aussi grâce à ces fêtes un supplément de
bonheur c'est tout ce que je vous
souhaite pour 1973 à partir de ce 20
juillet au revoir et à bientôt